since the turn of the century technology
has rapidly improved our reality is now
filled with things that were mere dreams
in the past few decades seeing how the
past is unfolded I was curious about
what the next 30 Years would look like
so why did a little digging into what
life might look like in 2050 for us
let's take a look nanotechnology
first let's take a look at
nanotechnology over the years scientists
have made exciting developments and
discovered numerous Innovative
applications for nanotechnology as it
stands nanotechnology has the potential
to change Life as We Know It experts in
the field believe that Nanobots will in
the future be fitted into our brains to
connect us to the virtual world more
readily and faster with the use of brain
computer interface technology the mind
and computer will be won making humans
very powerful beings with access to
endless information and solutions to
problems that the Mind wouldn't be able
to solve if nanotechnology reaches that
stage there may be no need for gadgets
like phones and calculators well this is
very exciting for the student of the
future looks like math will not be a
universal challenge much longer 3D print
technology
the next tech advancement that we can
expect in the future is the rise of 3D
print technology 3D print technology is
already advanced but we can expect it to
be even more advanced in 2050. right now
we have 3D printed tools and homes in
the future we will be able to print more
tools and perhaps even some modes of
transportation if bigger machines are
built this technology will also become
more accessible to everyone who may want
a 3D printer making the possibilities of
what can be printed infinite if the
current trend of Open Source 3D
printable files continues it will not be
long before everyone prints their own
large objects like furniture and weapons
well here's an idea how about developing
an affordable 3D printer for food that
could be the end of world hunger despite
global warming medical now we go from
the extinction of phones to the
eradication of death well by 2050 the
finality of death may be a thing of the
past with the brain connected to a
computer through BCI technology the
information stored in our brains can be
transferred into a hard disk like
computer files that means the data
including memories can be retrieved and
uploaded into another being maybe a more
advanced humanoid robot this way the
best Minds in every field will be
preserved and able to continue working
on Innovations another Improvement to
consider in the medical field is that
serious diseases like cancer will be
cured the only downside to this
development is that every new technology
is very expensive when it first comes
out so the rest of us may not have
access to this literally life-saving
technology for a while Transportation
something that we may have access to is
transportation in 2050 Transportation
will have immensely changed with
experimentation focused on self-driving
cars already underway from car
manufacturers such as Tesla it is not
much of a stretch to believe that by
2050 the technology for fully automated
Vehicles will exist some notable
advantages of such automated Vehicles
include a drastic reduction in traffic
related deaths because the vehicles will
collaborate with traffic control system
another Advantage is the change in
lifestyle that self-driving Vehicles
will bring with no need to man a vehicle
people will be free to choose whether to
relax or be more productive as they
travel a lot of free time considering
the amount of time spent in traffic
another interesting development is the
hyperloop one project by Elon which aims
to move the bulk of public
transportation underground with the use
of electromagnetic levitation at
historic speeds of 310 kilometers per
hour this train presents the opportunity
for a faster cheaper and cleaner mode of
transportation and if more people opt
for it then there will be even fewer
traffic related incidents fuel
still on Transportation the fuel used in
all future Transportation modes will be
renewable energy currently the world is
plagued by global warming and the threat
of depleting natural resources so we do
need to be looking at adapting to a more
sustainable source of energy now
hyperloop one is exploring
electromagnetic levitation and the
automobile industry has also been
looking for ways to reduce harmful
vehicle emissions these are all efforts
aimed at achieving the goal of stopping
the use of carbon emitting fuels besides
those research is being done on the
ocean's wind solar and thermal energy
one company in particular blue rise a
specialist developer of ocean thermal
energy conversion is working on a
project that could completely phase out
the use of fossil fuels hopefully blue
rise and their colleagues will be
successful soon enough to alleviate some
of the environmental problems we Face
space exploration
now if there is one thing that has been
mentioned as a mitigating option for our
current environmental challenges it's
space exploration and colonization
companies like SpaceX and blue origin
are set on revolutionizing Space
technology with goals of spatial
exploration and ultimately enabling
people to live on other planets in
colonies with all the strides already
made by 2050 space tourism will also be
a reality for those who can afford it
the possibilities for holiday
destinations will expand to include
places like Mars and the moon
unfortunately a trip to orbit will be
significantly expensive making it
exclusive for the extremely wealthy at
least at First artificial intelligence
something that may be available for
everyone is artificial intelligence
already more advanced than most of the
Innovations mentioned here the
development of artificial intelligence
will only get better Through The Years
experts in the field believe that AI
will surpass the processing power of
living brains that wouldn't be scary if
it didn't open the door to the
robo-apocalypse luckily scientists still
have to figure out how to impart all the
important human values into an AI before
it can become a part of our everyday
life but the rise of AI will of course
change the face of the workforce not
only that but the job market will also
face radical change and with the way
things are going about half of the
world's current jobs will be extinct
taken over by AI machines and robots in
2050 the world will be more
interconnected and even more driven by
data than it is now some of us will
definitely need to consider a career
change education as the job market
changes education will also see some
significant changes already there has
been an increase in digital learning
especially during the pandemic by 2050
completely digital schools will be
commonplace even if we have physically
attended schools they will have no need
for books using tablets and laptops
instead for higher education experts
believe that more than 70 percent of the
student population will be enrolled in
online degrees making education more
globalized a rather welcome step in the
right direction if we are to make good
education accessible to all I believe
online degrees may even be taught by
ai-powered robots at that time I imagine
the robots will be able to prepare
course material give lectures and Mark
assignments sadly you may be unable to
twist your lecturer's arm so they give
you a deadline extension the metaverse
Now we move on to the metaverse since
Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg announced
it virtual reality and AI have been
assimilated into our everyday life
through the social media giant for those
who may be a bit confused about the
metaverse you're not alone and you've
come to the right place the metaverse is
a virtual reality computer-generated
environment in which you can interact
with other users through AI enabled
software so it's about simulation with
avatars representing users as metaverse
functions get more developed by 2050 it
will be able to offer a full virtual
experience that includes shopping to
travel right from the comfort of your
own home people will have the option to
share their virtual experiences with the
World Imagine taking a trip to your
favorite holiday destination with your
family only you're not physically there
that's what the metaverse will offer it
seems to me like the more we get
connected the more we stay apart money
next is money even though we will still
use money one thing that has been used
less and less over the years is Cash
keeping up with that Trend cash will
most likely no longer be used in 2050.
all transactions will be done virtually
and new modes of financial transactions
will emerge because of AI and
decentralized finance as the world
slowly starts to adopt those
Technologies we may not even have to do
our own grocery shopping anymore making
traditional paper and plastic money even
less useful like Tesla which orders its
own car parts as needed our automated
pantries and refrigerators May order our
groceries no more getting the wrong milk
or even Running Out of Milk real estate
speaking of the automation of Home
Appliances the homes in 2050 will also
be completely automated Smart Homes
although Smart Homes already exist the
developments that will be available in
the next few decades will be a great
Improvement to what we have now Smart
Homes in 2050 will have full AI
activation functions allowing the home
to sense our moods and requirements
without giving it a single command
additionally interactive hologram
televisions will exist meaning that you
can verbally call up your hologram TV
and it will appear right in front of you
the best part you will never have to
look for the remote again because you
can control the TV with your mind using
nanotechnology as discussed at the
beginning of the video so with that we
have come full circle in this video of
exploring what our lives will look like
in 2050. to be honest this is just an
exercise of imagination and I realized
that not everything discussed in this
video will come true however you'd have
to agree that none of this is too
far-fetched either as Humanity has
already planted the roots of many of
these Technologies anyways one thing is
for certain in with how technology is
progressing I have no doubt that the
world will be very different by 2050 but
I do hope that our current societal
systems and structures will be able to
cope with these coming Innovations so
what do you think of these future
Innovations do you think this is what
life will look like in 2050 let me know
in the comment section below if you
enjoyed this video hit the Subscribe
button and continue watching by clicking
on one of the cards on your screen see
you in the next one